[Music]
on this Sunday night in a holding
pattern hundreds of Canadians trapped in
China it's frustrating to say the least
the complications Canada faces to get
citizens home we're waiting for
permission from the Chinese government
as the new coronavirus claims a life
outside of China the race for the
Democratic nomination why the Iowa
caucuses count plus the US president's
war on birth tourism and the Canadian
doctor competing in the Superbowl
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us the new corona virus has reached a
grim milestone a 44 old man in the
Philippines has become the first death
outside of China
the death toll in China the epicenter of
the outbreak is now over 350 more than
16,000 people have become infected
hundreds of Canadians remain stranded in
the country the Canadian government has
chartered a plane that is on standby to
get them home
Ottawa insists it is waiting for the
Chinese government to give an
authorization to land once that happens
the plane will head to Canadian Forces
Base Trenton where the evacuees will
undergo health screenings the crew and
Canadians returning will then be
quarantined at the base for 14 days
but as abigail Beeman explains there's a
lot of confusion among permanent
residents we really want to go home
Canada is our home Ben Jung's two young
kids are Canadian citizens he and his
wife permanent residents Canada says
China won't let permanent residents on
the Canadian evacuation flight but
Chinese officials told him they have no
such policy now he has no idea whether
his family of four will be allowed to
board it's frustrating to say the least
but again we are all hopeful we expected
more communications from them so even if
it's just to say hey guys just letting
you know that we know that you're in
China we're there for you and we're
working on something a crew is trained
and ready to go we're waiting for
manifests to know which passengers are
on that plane and we're waiting for
permission from the Chinese government
we've offered to help China with medical
supplies we're doing everything we
should do but we're also not panicking
while the government still can't say
when the flight will leave Global News
has obtained this email sent to
Canadians in Hebei it tells people to
submit personal information to global
affairs by Monday and says they'll try
to provide 24 hours notice before the
flight but it also says space is limited
and may not be guaranteed the latest
numbers show 325 people want to get out
there could be more passengers than
seats on the one flight in the works
Global Affairs
it will keep working to get Canadians
out I actually prefer to stay Hana with
my parents félicité Fang runs a
restaurant with her husband in Montreal
but is visiting her parents in her
hometown Wu hen her father is helping
build one of two new hospitals for
coronavirus patients he's one of the few
people outside all day and allowed to
drive my whole life I never seen one
like this it's kind of scary it's very
very quiet I feels like living scary
movie scary too for those waiting for
information from Ottawa about getting
out with so many unanswered questions
about who can board the plane and what
will happen when it lands back in Canada
the email from Global Affairs says only
one carry-on bag allowed per person one
family tells me their bags are packed
ready to leave at a moment's notice
Robin abigail demon in ottawa citizens
for more than half a dozen other
countries have been able to get out of
China
thanks to their governments today more
than a hundred Australians in Wuhan
boarded a flight that will take them to
Christmas Island where they'll spend the
next two weeks in quarantine and tonight
there are reports six Chinese officials
have been fired for how they handled the
outbreak Ross Lorde reports more than
200 Indonesia nationals arrived home
after being moved out of China mostly
from ube province their next move being
flown to another location away from
residential neighborhoods
this police official hopes placing them
in quarantine will run smoothly a
growing number of countries are moving
their citizens to safety something
Canadian officials have signaled they
are ready to do the government has
secured a chartered aircraft and is now
working on the diplomatic front with
officials in China to obtain the
authorizations to proceed with an
assisted departure this latest crisis is
occurring after a long period of
instability in Hong Kong and as you are
well aware a difficult year in Canada
China relations but hundreds of
Canadians are still in limbo the
Philippines meantime has a dubious
distinction of 44 year old Chinese man
developed severe pneumonia and died this
is the first reported death outside
China however we need to take into mind
that this is not a locally acquired case
this patient came from the epic center
of this outbreak Wuhan China the
Philippines has blocked entry to
travelers from China New Zealand Iraq
and Indonesia are also imposing new
restrictions health authorities in
Canada suggest the risk of individual
infections is relatively low urging
people to practice good hygiene just in
case
but inside China authorities have fired
six officials in ube province for
handling the outbreak poorly New York
Times report claims the government puts
secrecy and order ahead of confronting
the corona virus to keep the public from
panicking and to avoid political
embarrassment the number of confirmed
cases could keep growing because
thousands of specimens from suspected
cases have yet to be tested
a long way to go before this public
health crisis goes away Ross Lord Global
News a man shot dead by police after he
went on a stabbing rampage in London was
released from prison just days ago after
serving time for terror offences today's
attack happened in South London in the
afternoon witnesses say a man armed with
a machete walked into a shop and stabbed
a man in the stomach before he fled and
stabbed a woman on a bicycle he appeared
to be wearing a suicide vest later
deemed a hoax and sparked a bomb scare
when he dropped a bag on the road there
was no explosive device but undercover
officers took no chances and shot him
dead police say they are confident the
suspect is Sudesh Amin who was in his
early 20s he has served half of a
three-year sentence for spreading
extremist Islamist material he was under
police surveillance at the time of the
attack britain's Foreign Secretary says
the UK will not be aligning with the
European Union's trade rules instead it
wants a deal similar to the EU
arrangement with Canada Britain and the
EU are expected to start negotiating a
future trade framework in March today
Dominic Rob said Britain is seeking a
deal that imposes very few tariffs like
a Canada style free trade pact with
Europe and its member states we will not
be insisting that they align with our
rules of the price of a free trade deal
with the UK that's not the way through
trade bills are done globally and I'm
sure that we you'll want to adhere to
their commitment to a Canada style
best-in-class free trade agreement and
there's great opportunity there on all
sides British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson will spell out his government's
trade stance in a speech tomorrow in the
US Democrats are gearing up for a big
day in the race to take on President
Donald Trump the Iowa caucuses take
place tomorrow the first chance for
candidates to face voters the field is
narrowed but there are still 11
candidates vying for the Democratic
nomination
tomorrow's outcome
could see presidential hopes fade for a
number of them it's the first in a long
run of caucuses and primaries as
Jennifer Johnson reports even the
frontrunners have a fight ahead of them
before one of them goes head-to-head
with Trump Democratic presidential
candidates courting Iowa voters on the
eve of their first campaign showdown
Monday night's Iowa caucus the entire
nation looking to this state of just
over three million voters to see who
they think should take over the White
House this is it this is our moment in
history in this final sprint candidates
are making last-minute pitches to Iowans
voters hearing from those leading the
pack
senators Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren and former Vice President Joe
Biden we need a president to party unite
our country as president Trump predicts
his own reelection a new NBC news/wall
Street Journal poll shows the president
trailing Biden Sanders and Warren in
that poll the president is also behind
mayor Pete Budaj
the first openly gay presidential
candidate I think I'm the best candidate
to bring people together now Sanders
Warren and senator Amy Klobuchar have
had to interrupt their campaigns for the
Senate impeachment trial of President
Trump
duty calls and I think you all know how
important this hearing was this week in
2016 Donald Trump lost in Iowa to
Senator Ted Cruz right or wrong people
here are aware how powerful their
decision is I view this as a certainly
important election because we live in a
divided time our leader is very much
trying to divide us with hate and I
really think we need to win this
election as the Senate impeachment trial
continues Monday
the eyes of Americans will also be
focused on Iowa as their voters decide
who should be the Democratic Party's
nominee Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington it's only a matter of time
before the republican-controlled US
Senate acquits President Trump in his
impeachment trial Republicans and
Democrats will begin their closing
arguments on Monday on Friday senators
voted against calling new witnesses
including Trump's former national
security adviser John Bolton Bolton
soon-to-be
book reportedly provides new details
about the president's efforts to put
pressure on Ukraine to investigate
Democratic presidential candidate Joe
Biden one Republican senator argues
Bolton's testimony wouldn't have changed
the outcome of the trial I mean if you
have eight witnesses who say someone
left the scene of an accident why do you
need nine I mean that's question for me
was do I need more evidence to conclude
that the President did what he did and I
concluded no a new poll from NBC News
and The Wall Street Journal found 52
percent of registered voters believed
the president abused his power but
voters remain divided over whether he
should be removed from office a slim
majority 49 percent believe Trump should
remain in the White House still to come
a mudslide at a resort in DC leaves
hundreds stranded and the threat of
coronavirus to businesses in Canada a
landslide has left hundreds of people
stranded at a ski resort in DC the slide
happened Friday evening after heavy
rainfall across the southern part of the
province the Sasquatch Mountain Resort
is about a hundred and thirty kilometres
east of Vancouver near the community of
Agassiz the road leading to and from the
resort is impassable and it could take
up to six days to clear it a helicopter
has been hired to airlift people out of
the area but at a cost of a hundred and
fifty dollars per person the coronavirus
scare is being felt by business owners
across Canada
travel agencies restaurants even grocery
stores are all feeling the effects
here's Dan specter Eric who runs dobby
and andy restaurant in Montreal's
chinatown lunch time is usually busy but
this week things started off really slow
he thinks people may have been scared
away by coronavirus gradually got better
during the week and not just normal at
this gift shop they said things are
slower than usual it weren't the only
ones to say so off camera
it's affected actually how many trips
james ma runs a travel agency he says
some of his clients are stranded because
of air canada suspending all flights to
china and that he's being forced to
cancel trips that had already been
booked January February March April I
think will have no revenue with no
indication of when travel to China will
be back to normal he's expecting a big
hit like this dumpling shop has not
noticed any slowdown but has seen one
difference people start to panicking and
they were a lot be aware mass there have
been reports of racism against Chinese
Canadians related to the virus but
Calvin Lam said he's just noticed the
usual canola virus not yet in spite of
tightening travel restrictions and
misinformation swirling across Canada in
Vancouver's Chinatown the biggest in the
country people we spoke to said things
seemed normal
someone called thanks to me it comes to
my mind but back at Toby and Andy in
Montreal they feel after a period of
alarm the fear seems to have died down
there's no real reason to stay home and
they just came back out you know and
their hope is that things will continue
to be business as usual Dan Specter
Global News Montreal still ahead the
politics behind Trump's crackdown on
birth tourism
want weather on-the-go pinpointed with
the free global news sky tracker weather
app reliable accurate and easy to use
it's like having a direct line to a
meteorologist the global news sky
tracker weather app forecast calls for
download
[Music]
you are watching global national a
[Music]
tragic turn of events at a church
meeting in Tanzania 20 people including
five children were crushed to death
during a stampede
it happened in Moshe near the slopes of
Mount Kilimanjaro on Saturday hundreds
were there to listen to a popular
preacher who promises prosperity and
cures for sickness the Stampede was
caused when the church faithful rushed
to walk on anointed oil to be healed the
preacher has since been arrested
Somalia declared a national emergency
today as large swarms of locusts spread
across East Africa the United Nations
says the swarms are the largest ever
seen in Somalia and in Ethiopia in 25
years the desert locust is considered
the most dangerous of its species they
fly together by the millions devouring
crops Somalia's Ministry of Agriculture
says the insects pose a major threat to
the country's already fragile food
security situation President Donald
Trump's controversial new policy is
putting the spotlight back on
immigration the US will no longer issue
visas to pregnant women from certain
countries to crack down on so-called
birth tourism which guarantees children
born in America automatic citizenship
but as Reggie Cecchini reports critics
argue the problem isn't as big as the
president claims and is being used to
rally his base in an election year in a
crucial election year for US president
Donald Trump his administration is once
again using immigration as a rallying
cry they really believe that immigration
is not great for the country the latest
target pregnant women who want to give
birth in America women in their view are
reduced to you know their reproductive
capacity the u.s. gives citizenship at
birth everything that you have is
guaranteed welfare public benefits right
it's led to a rise in birth tourism now
travel visas won't be issued to pregnant
women unless they have a valid reason
for visiting the White House claims the
policy is necessary to enhance public
safety and national security this is
just one more policy in a long line of
MS
gotten immigration policies that assumes
that all immigrants are presumptively
lawbreakers but it raises questions on
the burden of proof for women it's
denying them the right to travel and
just in case they might be pregnant
it's all about control of women's bodies
to combat birth tourism in the Northern
Mariana Islands a u.s. territory
officials have requested that some
airlines administer pregnancy tests as a
part of a fit to fly assessment that
practice is no longer in use president
Trump has used immigration in the past
to spark fear in his base they're
bringing crime they're rapists but this
move isn't trying to stop border jumpers
it's trying to end birthright
citizenship the courts would not let him
do it and so it's a promise that you can
make and then you can blame others for
making it impossible to happen it's
estimated that in the US alone 10,000
babies were born to foreign mothers in
2017 that number probably includes
plenty of people who are here for
totally legitimate other reasons birth
tourism is not uniquely American it's a
growing issue in Canada to Richmond BC
has become a destination for foreign
expectant mothers consular officials in
the u.s. won't question all pregnant
women raising concerns about how
effective this new policy will be when
you're pregnant your life continues and
how immigration in the US has once again
become the focus of an election campaign
Reggie Cecchini Global News Washington
up next how the Canadian doctor went
from tackling medicine to tackling the
Superbowl
[Applause]
it's Groundhog Day yet again but with
some conflicting opinions in Wiarton
Ontario Willie emerged from his burrow
and did not see his shadow signaling an
early spring but only after the town's
mayor Janice Jackson misinterpreted it
announcing winter was staying put she
did correct herself though and the other
rodent in Nova Scotia had his handlers
take to social media to let the public
know she benaki D Sam did see his shadow
which could mean at least six more weeks
of winter great footwork from Ricky but
le in the UK it was a rough Super League
debut for the Toronto Wolfpack in its
first match as part of the top division
the team's 23 game winning streak came
to an end with a 28 10 loss against the
Castleford Tigers none of the team's
players is Canadian they trained in the
UK for most of the year but they're
hoping more success in the league will
attract more support from Canadian
athletes and fans alike a Canadian is
making football history today
Lawal dewfall natal death is the first
medical doctor to play in the NFL and in
a Super Bowl the 28 year old is part of
the Kansas City Chiefs offensive line
and as Amanda jela wiki reports the
Quebecker is managing to juggle two
careers
[Music]
for years advisers told the wrong to
burn a turd if to make a choice
professional football or medicine doing
both they said was impossible he didn't
listen now
the Montreal native becomes the first
doctor to compete in the Superbowl I was
doing it for me but also to prove
everybody that they were wrong
twenty-eight-year-old duverney tardif
attended McGill University studying
medicine he quickly became a star on the
football field - sorry for try from the
beginning I mean just a simple sighs was
was quite staggering to see but after
just his technique his dream though was
never to win a Super Bowl but to become
an emergency room physician he told me
always if Miguel doesn't allow me to
continue my med school in the offseason
I'm not gonna continue football after
the Kansas City Chiefs drafted him in
2014 McGill agreed to a part-time
schedule and despite signing a 42
million dollar contract he kept working
in medicine patients saw this massive
guy come in there was no gloves almost
that would fit him it was always the
largest sized glove possible the gowns
looked overly small on him he absolutely
was outperforming many of his peers he
did very well he followed a grueling
schedule in the offseason exercising
studying and working late in hospitals
he completed his degree in eight years
instead of four that's the hardest part
of my career and my year is to like
transition from football last game of
the season to first ship in the hospital
at 6:00 in the morning as a medical
student at the bottom of the food chain
two years after graduating he's in the
Superbowl and his hometown is
celebrating for a Montrealer to be in
the biggest sporting event in the world
which is never happened before I think
it's pretty incredible Ashley I tell
them all times listen you're not here
but there's a lot of people that are
supporting you the province is behind
you the countries
as I McGill Brad I'm very excited to see
a right guard from from McGill who
happens to be a doctor as well that's a
source of pride for all Canadians and
win or lose
he's already accomplished so much Metta
Gela wiki Global News Montreal what a
great story that is global national for
this Sunday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is Lethbridge Alberta thank you
for watching
Donna freeze and we'll be here tomorrow
and I'll see you next weekend have a
great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]